hello we're glad you joined us for
today's keynote presentation prefrontal
GABA regulation of cognition
implications for psychiatric disorders I
am Christina mahalik of libraries and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit lab routes comm let's
get started you can pose questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing a presentation just click on the
support button found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the screen
this is an educational webinar and this
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the Cee button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits it is now my pleasure to present
today's keynote speaker stan fluoresce
co ph.d professor Department of
Psychology University of British
Columbia dr. Stan fluoresce Co is a
professor of psychology and member of
the brain Research Center at the
University of British Columbia and a
fellow of the American College of
neuropsychopharmacology Jiri sweet
received all of his postgraduate degrees
from UBC obtaining his PhD in 2000 he
subsequently conducted postdoctoral
research in the department of
neuroscience
the University of Pittsburgh after which
he returned to UBC to take up a faculty
position in 2003 three dr. kloor ESCO
has published over 90 peer-reviewed
articles on his research employing
behavioral and neurophysiological
approaches to study neural circuits
within the dopamine system that
facilitates higher order cognitive
functions such as cognitive flexibility
and cost benefit decision making and how
dysfunction in these circuits may relate
to psychiatric disease he currently
serves as an associate editor for the
journals cognitive affective and
behavioral neuroscience and
neuropsychopharmacology and in 2010 he
was awarded the American Physiological
association's early career award
dr. fluoroscope will now begin his
presentation Thank You laberd's for
bestowing to me the honor of giving this
keynote address and giving me the
opportunity to talk to all of you today
about some work my colleagues and I have
been focusing on over the last five or
six years or so trying to understand how
inhibitory transmission within the
frontal lobes may regulate different
aspects of cognition and with a
particular emphasis on how dysfunction
within this system may relate to some of
the symptomology we see in psychiatric
disorders now we initially started this
line of research with the interest in
schizophrenia and how dysfunction of the
system may relate to schizophrenia
symptom ology but the fact is is that
dysfunction within inhibitory GABA
transmission in the prefrontal cortex
may accumulate to a variety of different
types of symptoms absorbs across
different disease domains now when one
thinks of schizophrenia one typically
envisioned that's what we refer to as
the psychotic or a positive symptoms the
delusions the paranoia the
hallucinations the voices
people complain about these are the
symptoms we can see someone else
suffering from they make us feel
uncomfortable but there is of course a
silent suffering associated with
schizophrenia as well that takes a form
of negative symptoms impairments and
motivation emotional regulation and in
particular impairments in cognitive
functioning this idea that schizophrenia
is associated with cognitive disruption
is not new it dates back to some of the
original descriptions of disorder by
picking crepin who originally labeled
the syndrome dementia praecox early
dementia
now even though schizophrenia presents
with both psychotic and these cognitive
symptoms it doesn't seem to be much
overlap between them in terms of the
mechanisms that may mediate these
because there doesn't seem to be any
strong correlation between the severity
of these two symptoms you can have an
individual who is very actively
psychotic but may also be
high-functioning cognitively and you can
have other situations where a patient
may have relatively subdued symptoms but
shows pronounced cognitive deficits now
the emphasis on cognitive dysfunction
the schizophrenia really has turned up a
lot in the last 10-15 years because
studies have revealed that cognitive
functioning of an individual suffering
from schizophrenia is his or hers best
predictor of their long-term functional
outcome and those who show better
cognition tend to perform better in the
real world and they have a better
prognosis so they are more likely to be
able to live by themselves and hold down
a job compared to individuals who show
poor cognitive functioning so
understanding the mechanisms that
underlies a cognitive dysfunction we see
in this disorder is a crucial first step
in helping device treatments that may
ameliorate some of these deficits and
improve the long-term outcome of the
patients so in terms of the mechanisms
that underlie schizophrenia symptom
ology there have been numerous
hypotheses that have been put forth many
of these focus on dysfunctions within
certain neurotransmitters so perhaps the
most well-known and oldest hypothesis we
have of what drive some of schizophrenia
symptoms is what's referred to as the
Delta
hypothesis that there may be too much
dopamine activity within certain brain
regions within the schizophrenic patient
the key piece of evidence to support
this is that all the drugs that we
currently have that are effective at
treating psychosis treating these
positive symptoms block dopamine
transmission particularly the d2
receptor of dopamine to some degree and
recent imaging studies have shown that
individuals who suffer from
schizophrenia show increased dopamine
release in certain sub cortical brain
regions so there is strong evidence to
suggest that exacerbated dopamine
transmission may contribute to release
some of the symptoms associated with
schizophrenia but the fact is is that
antipsychotics drugs that block dopamine
receptors are relatively ineffective and
treating these cognitive deficits and
treating the negative symptoms so
dopamine may be driving more of these
positive symptoms but other neural
abnormalities may be more related to the
negative and cognitive symptoms we see
in this disorder complementary
hypothesis has been referred to as the
glutamate hypothesis glutamate is the
primary excitatory neurotransmitter in
the brain and it is used by the
principal neurons in the cerebral cortex
and other key structures involving
cognition such as the hippocampus and
there is some evidence to suggest that
there may be deficient
glutamatergic transmission within these
brain regions than they underlie some of
schizophrenia symptoms for one we know
that if we give drugs that reduce
glutamatergic signaling particularly
those that target the NMDA receptor
subtype of glutamate receptors that
these drugs can induce both psychotic
and cognitive symptoms that resemble
what we see in schizophrenic patients in
otherwise healthy individuals and these
drugs can also exacerbate these symptoms
in patients diagnosed with schizophrenia
furthermore we know that if we look at
post-mortem brains of individuals who
suffered schizophrenia we see
alterations and atrophy in neurons that
use glutamate as in your transmitter
so what this figure down here has shown
you is comparing what's referred to as a
pyramidal neuron from the cerebral
cortex of a healthy individual compared
to I'm neuron that was taken from the
brain of a schizophrenic subject you can
see there's considerable atrophy and
what this figure is showing you here is
that there are fewer synaptic contacts
in the neurons of patients suffering
from schizophrenia suggesting that there
may be reduced glutamatergic
transmission that contributes to these
symptoms now this is their strong
evidence to support this hypothesis but
yet another hypothesis that has been put
forward is that there may be dysfunction
within inhibitory GABA transmission
within the frontal lobes
now gaba is the primary inhibitory
transmitter in the brain and within the
cerebral cortex this neurotransmitter
comes from GABAergic inter neurons
smaller neurons that are distributed
throughout the cortex that serve as a
major information filter for the frontal
lobes and other regions and these
neurons are thought to regulate also
Tory activity certain patterns of brain
waves that underlying cognitive function
now there are numerous subtypes of these
GABAergic neurons one that has been
studied very commonly are what we refer
to as power of albumin gabber you can
announce they're labeled so because they
contain the specific protein part of
albumin that is neuroprotective and what
I'm showing you in this diagram here is
two examples of these types of PV inter
neurons and one thing we know about
these cells is that one individual
GABAergic in turn may send projections
and make contacts with many different
principal pyramidal neurons of the
cortex so that one individual cell may
be able to regulate and inhibit the
activity of up to 80 different pyramidal
cells so one cell has great inhibitory
regulatory control over larger networks
of prefrontal neurons now what we know
from studies of post-mortem brains of
schizophrenics is that reductions in
markers for these GABAergic neurons
particularly these
mignons is one of the most reliable
pathologies that has been observed in
the brains of schizophrenic patients
studies from numerous groups around the
world looking at different patient
populations have repeatedly show that
there are reduction in these GABAergic
interneurons within the prefrontal
cortex of schizophrenic patients as well
other parts of the brain so this is the
first piece of evidence to suggest that
gaba transmission may be dysfunctional
within this disease other neuro
physiological studies also add support
to this idea so as I told you before
certain types of cognitive functions
that are mediated by the frontal lobes
are associated with specific patterns of
oscillatory activity brain rhythms that
facilitate certain types of cognitive
functions so when a healthy individual
is performing a working memory task
where they have to hold and manipulate
information in mind for a brief period
of time that is associated with
oscillatory activity in what's called
the gamma range where you see
oscillations within the 40 Hertz range
while patients with schizophrenia show
impairments on these types of tasks and
also show altered oscillatory activity
and we know that this also is Hori
activity is driven by these gaba Ettrick
in your notes suggesting that this
alteration and behavior and brain
rhythms may be due to dysfunctional
transmission within this system now one
way that we can further understand how
certain types of brain pathology may
contribute to certain symptoms of a
disease is by using animal markets and
there have been numerous animal models
that have been designed to induce some
sort of insult in the brain that has
some relevance to what may be going on
in schizophrenia some of these models
may God involve genetic alterations
pharmacological or neurodevelopmental
alterations each of these models alter
changes in the behavior that in some
regards reflect what we see in patients
with schizophrenia but when we look at
the brains of these animals
subjected these models and look at the
alterations that we see one thing that
is consistent across these different
types of models is they all seem to
target this inhibitory system within the
frontal lobes so genetic models that
involve altering the genome of certain
animals in this example this is a data
of using a disc one knockout disc stands
for disrupted in schizophrenia it's a
gene that has been identified in
patients with schizophrenia if we knock
out this gene in animals and let them
develop we see impairments and cognition
and behavior that resemble what we see
in schizophrenia and we also see a
reduction in these power of human these
pv governorship neurons in the frontal
lobes what's more if we use a
pharmacological model if we give a drug
that blocks glutamate NMDA receptors as
I told you these drugs can induce
psychotic and cognitive symptoms and
otherwise healthy individuals we also
see changes in behavior in animals that
resemble what we see in schizophrenia
when we give these same drugs and these
drugs also seem to reduce GABAergic
transmission within the prefrontal
cortex causing a reduction in markers
for these neurons similar to what we see
in the schizophrenic patients
neurodevelopmental models involve giving
some sort of insult early in development
altering the trajectory of brain
development these models also change
behavior like we see in schizophrenia
and again one thing these manipulations
seem to do is reduce the number of
inhibitory interneurons within the
frontal cortex so when we look at all
these pieces of evidence together the
post-mortem studies from schizophrenic
patients then your physiological studies
and the work from animal models they all
lend themselves to a hypothesis is that
perturbations in inhibitory GABA signal
may lead to what some is referred to as
a noisy cortex that can in turn impair
cognitive functions mediated by the
frontal lobes now this seems like a
reasonable hypothesis base
what I've told you but the truth is
until recently there hasn't really been
a lot of basic preclinical research
designed to really isolate and identify
what the contribution of inhibitory GABA
transmission is in regulating cognition
what is its function so that's what we'd
been interested in doing over the last
few years what are the consequences of
reducing prefrontal GABA activity on
different cognitive functions that was
our primary question and as a secondary
but important question is when we do
these types of manipulations do the
alterations in cognition that we see
resemble impairments that we see in
patients with schizophrenia or for that
matter patients with other types of
psychiatric disorders and so in this
regard preclinical studies with
laboratory animals can help address
these questions so our basic
experimental approach was rather
straightforward rather than trying to
develop a new model of the disease
trying to identify a different type of
brain insult that may be relevant
directly to what may be going on in
schizophrenia we've gone with a more
basic research approach where we've
assessed the effects of pharmacological
reductions of prefrontal gaba
transmission on different domains of
cognition that you know are affected in
schizophrenia and in so doing we used a
very simple approach where we would
infuse low doses of a drug that we know
can reduce activity of gaba by blocking
the receptor that it works on and the
drug we use is called by cue cooling and
again we're using small volumes and
doses of this drug that don't induce any
types of seizures but just slightly
disinhibited the activity within this
cortical region now in these studies
what we did to try to increase its
translational value was try to pick
particular tasks that measure different
domains of cognition that relate
directly to the types of tasks that are
used in human subjects so that we may
directly translate the findings we find
with laboratory rats
to what we see in patients with
schizophrenia and in picking these tasks
we tried to pick those that gave us
richer patterns of behavior so we can
identify not just whether a certain
manipulation impairs cognition but look
at the specific types of impairments
that we see when we do this manipulation
so that we can identify both qualitative
and quantitative changes in behavior so
just because the manipulation may impair
cognition what we wanted to see is that
does this manipulation impair cognition
in the same way that we see cognition
impaired and schizophrenia
now I want to emphasize that we were
trying to model schizophrenia per se we
don't believe that this manipulation is
a direct model because it has very low
construct validity schizophrenia is not
caused by someone infusing a drug in
someone's brain but rather what our
primary focus on was to see how GABA
regulates these different modes of
cognition with the hope that
understanding this can provide key
insights into how dysfunctional the
system may contribute to the behavioral
abnormalities associated with this and
other diseases that may be associated
with dysfunctional gaba transmission so
cognition is a big word and there are
many different domains of cognition that
are impaired in schizophrenia in the
early 2000s the National Institute of
Mental Health started an initiative they
refer to as the measurements and
treatments of research to improve
cognitions gets a frame also called the
matrix and the first part of this
initiative was to bring together
clinical neuroscientists put them in a
room and have them hammer out and
identify what are the specific domains
of cognition that we reliably see are
impaired and schizophrenia and these
seven domains were identified are listed
here
all these seven domains speed of
processing is one that refers to how
slow or how rapidly subject may be able
to make a correct response and a
particular type of task
I'm not going to talk about this domain
directly but what I will say is that in
almost all the studies I'll be
discussing today one thing that we see
is that when we reduce gamma
transmission animals are slower to make
correct choices they are more hesitant
in trying to ascertain what the
appropriate thing is to do with respect
to the other domains of cognition listed
here five of these we can test in
animals we still have not devised a test
for a verbal learning and memory to be
used with the oratory rod but we're
working on but of these remaining
domains I'm going to be talking about
work but we've measured them for
particular domains attention working
memory reasoning problem-solving and
spatial learning and memory
now many but not all of these domains
are mediated by the prefrontal cortex
and I say that because if we damage or
inactivate the prefrontal cortex and
humans or animals we see impairments and
processes such as selective attention
working memory and cognitive flexibility
so the first domain of cognition I'm
going to talk about is attention
this is a fundamental deficit that
patients with schizophrenia
Lewton me complain about they have
difficulty maintaining focus they're
easily distracted by other stimuli and
one way we can assess this in
experimental animals is by using serial
reaction time tasks where we flash a
stimulus in one location in the
environment for a very brief period of
time less than a second and required the
animal to tell us that it saw that
stimulus and aware Shindo so the way
these tasks work is we place an animal
in a certain chamber that has five
apertures and every five seconds or so a
light will flash in one of these
apertures for a brief period of time say
half a second and all the rat has to do
is after we flash the right the rat has
to approach that particular location
where the light was flashed it has to
stick its nose within that port and it's
telling us I saw the light now please
give me a tasty sugar pellet
now studies by a number groups over the
last few years have shown that this
aspect of attention is critically
dependent on normal inhibitory
transmission what I'm showing you below
in these graphs is studies from three
groups showing that if you reduce
prefrontal gaba transmission with a
variety of different drugs you get
noticeable impairments in attentional
accuracy that animals are more likely to
select the wrong aperture where the
light was flashed suggesting that they
either didn't notice where the light was
flashed or they thought it flashed in a
slightly different location and this
assay is loosely analogous to the
continuous performance test that is used
in human subjects and we see in patients
with schizophrenia they show impairments
on these types of tasks but one thing
with this particular assay is that even
though it tells you whether intention is
affected or not it doesn't necessarily
get to the type of deficit that we might
be seeing here what an animal makes an
incorrect response is it because it
didn't notice the light that was flashed
she didn't actually see it wasn't paying
attention or was it that maybe it
thought the light flash in a slightly
different location
it didn't appropriately encode where
that stimulus was so one way we can get
to that is by using a variation on this
attention to house that is referred to
as a sustained attention task here we're
just using one stimulus light that
either turns on on some trials or
doesn't and what we do is we get the rat
and tell us did you see a light or not
so on these trials we have what are
called signal trials when we flash a
central light in an operant chamber for
anywhere from 50 to 500 milliseconds and
after we flash that light briefly you
present the animal with two levers and
if we flash light and if the rat
detected it the rat has been trained to
say that if I saw the light I should
press one particularly in this example I
should press the left lever every time I
see the light
and this is registered as a hit or a
correct response and I found these
trials the animal presses the other
Libra the right lever that's an
incorrect response doesn't suggest that
they have missile light didn't see it or
what happened then we have intermixed
with these signal trials non signal
trials where no light flashes and then
after the absence of showing this light
we again present these two levers to the
wreck and now the rat has to do
something different now it has to press
the oppositely instead of the left
leaver it has to press the right leader
and what it's telling us now is that you
didn't flash me a light so I'm pressing
this sleeper so you don't you so you can
give me a peace reward and if it presses
the left lever the lever that is
normally associated with what it should
do when it sees a light we call this a
false alarm suggests that they maybe saw
something that wasn't there and what we
found is that when we reduce prefrontal
gaba transmission like these other
groups i've told you about
we also see impairments in attentional
performance when we look at what's
referred to as their vigilance index
which is a an index of their overall
performance on both signal and non
signal trials you can see that when we
reduce prefrontal gaba transmission
anoles show a market decrement
performance compared to control animals
shown in the white right circles here
but then when we looked more closely at
the types of errors and when they were
making errors what we found was that on
the signal trials on trials where we
flashed on the light and they had to
tell us I saw the light regardless of
whether it was half a second long or 50
milliseconds long there was actually no
difference between the treatment
conditions so animals had no problem in
detecting a stimulus that was there in
stayed what we saw was that reducing
prefrontal gaba transmission caused a
selective deficit in rejecting these
truck on trials where the light was not
shown so we saw an increase in the
number of false alarms which was
associated with a reduction in these
correct rejection trials so what this
suggests is that gaba does play a role
in regulating transmission our regulator
attention but it does so my selectively
helping to filter out irrelevant sting
line and will reduce this transmission
we see this selective increase in these
false alarm responding and interestingly
this same type of task has been back
translated for use with human subjects
and when this task was usually patients
who suffer from schizophrenia what they
found was one of their attentional
deficits was as we saw here an increase
in false Elan responded so there is some
translational link between what we're
seeing here and what's been observed
namely schizophrenic patients working
memory is another domain of cognition
that is critically dependent on normal
frontal lobe functioning as in and is
impaired in patients with schizophrenia
working memory refers to a collection of
cognitive operations that involve the
short-term maintenance and manipulation
of information in mind and one key
component of this function is being able
to just hold bits of information of mine
for a brief period of time one way we
can tap into that function is by using
what I referred to as delayed response
tasks we're subject is given information
it has to hold for a brief period of
time over a delay and then use that
information afterwards and in a
oculomotor delayed response to ask
that's reason both primates and humans
the way this game works is on a given
trial during a sample phase we prevent
the subject we present the subject with
a stimulus within one particular
location so on a screen will present a
dot in one particular location and then
after which there is a delay where no
stimuli presents
then during the choice phase what
happens is now we present a number of
different stimuli and the subject has to
orient his or her gaze to the same
position where that stimulus was
originally presented and then a new
trial starts new information is given
and they have to continue on for
hundreds of trials now patients with
schizophrenia show market impairments on
this type of task as I'm showing you in
this graph here and one thing I want you
to notice is that compared to healthy
controls patients with schizophrenia
show an impairment in working memory
regardless of how long the delay is so
they show poor performance at short
delays and poor performance at these
longer delays so this is a delay
independent impairment working memory
and suggests that this is so much a
problem of remembering the information
but other problems associated with
encoding that information and getting it
into a buffer to remember so we can test
the same basic function in animals using
an operant version of this delayed
response task works in a similar manner
to what I described to you before is
that we have a sample phase here we have
a light illuminated above one of two
levers and then a lever is presented the
rat presses that lever for a brief
period of time that initiates a delay
period where the animal has to wait
anywhere from 1 to 24 seconds and then
during the choice phase both levers are
presented both lights are illuminated
and we've talked the rat press the lever
opposite to the one that you press
during the sample phase in order to get
food reward we find that if we make the
cortex noise if we reduce inhibitory
GABA transmission we see a market
impairment in performance compared to
control conditions and like is observed
in schizophrenia this impairment working
memory seems to be delay independent
that animals show impairments and
performance even at the shortest one
second away and it doesn't seem to get
any worse when delay increases
so we see again a translational
qualitatively similar type of deficit
when we just reduced prefrontal gaba
in the rat that we see with patients
with schizophrenia to compare we also
looked at what happens when we disrupt
glutamatergic signaling within the
frontal lobes infusing a drug that
blocks NMDA receptors the same type of
drugs that can induce psychotic symptoms
and cognitive deficits in otherwise
healthy individuals here blocking
glutamate transmission also impaired
working memory but the type of deficit
was different here animals actually were
fine at the short delay but it's only
when these delays got longer did we see
an impairment performance so here we saw
a delay dependent impairment in working
memory suggesting that glutamate
transmission within the frontal lobes
may regulate more mnemonic maintenance
or retrieval of impure term information
so when we look at these two findings
together what this suggests is that
reduced glutamatergic signal information
coming from other sensory and other
parts of the cerebral cortex that inform
the prefrontal cortex and what it should
remember when that's combined with
increased noise that may occur when we
perturb GABAergic inhibition mainly to
what I refer to as a cortical cacophony
basically a hot mess of neural
transmission where signals that are
supposed to be getting in saying what
you should remember are blunted and
that's on top of a noisier baseline of
excessive aberrant hyperactivity that
may contribute to working memory
deficits that we see in schizophrenia
reasoning and problem-solving
there's also imperative schizophrenia in
particular certain forms of cognitive
flexibility having to adjust your
behavior in response to changes in one's
marking now in humans this type of
function is classically measured with a
say such as the Wisconsin card sorting
task where human subjects are given
decks of cards that have different
shapes on them different numbers of
items on them and these are different
colors and they are required to sort the
cards by a particular
stingless dimensions so initially they
may have to sort the cards based on the
color so put all the red cards together
all the blue cards together all the
yellow cards together and then unknown
to the subject the rule changes
midstream so now the subject has to sort
the cards by shape put all the triangles
together put all the stars together put
all the squares together now patients
with damage to the frontal lobe and
patients with schizophrenia are really
bad at this task there shall market
impairments of us in fact impairments in
cognitive flexibility is one of the most
reliable types of cognitive deficits
that have been observed in schizophrenia
now we can tap to the same basic type of
cognition having to adjust how you
discriminate and the strategies that you
have to use to solve a problem using a
simple task that we can use in rats in
an operant chamber so the way these
tasks works it's conducted over two days
and on the first day we teach a rat a
very simple rule on any given trial a
light is going to be illuminated over
one of the two levers and what the rat
has to do is press the lever that has
the light illuminated above it sometimes
it's on the Left sometimes it's on the
right and all has to do is where you see
the light go to that press the lever and
you'll get a tasty treat
rats can learn this very easy good in 30
or 40 trials to get to a criterion of
ten correct choices in a row the next
day however we change the game now the
new rule is always press the lever
within one particular location so might
be always press the left leaver now on
these days that light is still there
sometimes it flashes on the left
sometimes it flashes on the right now
what the rat has to do is that's to stop
using the old strategy stop paying
attention to this stimulus which is now
irrelevant fit and figure out what the
new strategy is in this case instead of
looking at the light and where that
position is I should focus on the pink
particular position of a lever and use
that strategy in order to solve this
now one reason why we like this
particular task is we can look at the
types of errors that animals make during
the shift that can give us additional
insight into how a certain manipulation
may impair different components of
cognitive flexibility so what can happen
on half of the trials is that the old
rule and the new rule on conflict if we
train the rat to always press a lever
with a light above and on the old day
and then on the shift now we see threat
always press the left lever on half of
the trials the light is above the right
waiver and so when the rat presses the
lever underneath the light on these
trials we refer to these as perseverate
of errors because they're persevering to
using the old strategy and we use these
errors as an index of how readily
animals learn to suppress using this old
rule but sometimes you'll have
situations where the old and the new
rule are congruent so the light may be
above the left lever and today we're
teaching the rat always press the left
leap well sometimes the rats gonna press
a lever that doesn't have a light
illuminate above it and these are
referred to as never reinforced or non /
separative errors when we use these
types of errors to ascertain how quickly
the animal might be able to figure out
the new rule to learn or establish this
new strategy now when we take a look at
patients with schizophrenia and see how
they perform on these types of tests
such as a Wisconsin card sorting test
what I'm showing you here is data from a
study done in 2003 and what we see is
that these patients they make a
considerable number of preservative
errors similar to what you see in
patients with frontal lobe damage so
they keep harping on the old strategy
but they also make a considerable number
of these non preservative errors
suggesting that they also have problems
in figuring out what the new strategy
should be
so when we see how reducing gamma
transmission within the frontal lobes of
rats affects the same basic behavioral
process well one thing we see is that if
we make the cortex noisy if we disrupt
inhibitory transmission when they're
learning that first rule when they're
learning this simple rule always press a
lever with the light above we see no
impairments in performance annals
perform just as well as control animals
so you don't need normal inhibitory
transmission to learn a simple
discrimination rule and this is
important because it shows that this
manipulation doesn't induce more gross
or fundamental deficits in learning or
motivational or other types of processes
but what we find was that when animals
now have to change the way they behave
have to use a new rule and figure out
what that rule is that disrupting
inhibitory transmission within the
frontal lobes causes a market impairment
performance and the type of impairment
we see was dependent in part on when
over the course of the learning sequence
we disrupted gaba transmission so if we
disrupted gaba transmission on the first
day when they were learning the first
rule the next day when they had to shift
we observed that they were markedly
impaired and showed these big per
serving of deficits they kept using the
old strategy had great difficulty in
figuring out what the new strategy was
whereas if we disrupted gaba
transmission on the day where they have
to change their behavior where they have
to learn a new rule here we see an
increase in these non preservative
errors here their big problem was trying
to figure out what the new strategy was
in both of these situations when you
look at the combined effects it
recapitulates the type of deficits that
we see in patients with schizophrenia
that show both preservative and non
preservative deficits and suggest that
dysfunction within gaba transmission
during key aspects of learning may
contribute to both types of deficits
that we see in patients
now spatial learning and memory is a
form of cognition that is very easy to
assessing loads it's something that they
are just built to do is navigate through
space and identify locations they should
you shouldn't go to and one way we can
assess this in rodents is by using
different versions of a radial arm maze
test that involves a central hub with a
number of arms radiating under the
center and in this particular asset
which is sometimes referred to as the
reference in words and memory tasks what
we do is we bait for the eight arms for
the eight arms contain little pieces of
food and it's the same for arms that are
baited each day and all the rat has to
learn over about twenty or thirty days
of training is just go down the arms
that contain food and never go down the
arms that have never contained food now
a well-turned rat can make two types of
errors on this task sometimes it might
go down an arm that has never contained
food and we refer to this as a reference
memory error this is a memory error for
long-term stable information it has
learned over many days never go here
there's nothing to see here but every
once in a while they may enter these
arms anyway what can also happen though
is sometimes a rat might go to an arm
take a piece of food leave that arm and
then maybe a minute later go back to
that same arm just a little memory blip
in terms of they forgot where they were
a minute ago and so we refer to these as
working or short-term memory errors so
this distinguishes between the
information memory errors for long term
stable information and more recently
acquired label information now one thing
I want to emphasize is that performance
of this task in a rat that has been
well-trained and knows this game does
not require normal activity within the
prefrontal cortex that's what these data
are showing you here if we take animals
train them on this task and then I'm
testing
shut down neural activity within the
frontal lobes basically completely
inactivated we see no significant
impairments in either types of errors so
you don't need the prefrontal cortex to
do this type of task other parts of the
brain such as the hippocampus play a
more crucial role in mediating
performance on this task but what we saw
was if we disinhibited the cortex rather
than shutting it down when we made it
noisy we got a massive impairment in
performance and when we looked at the
type of errors they made we saw that
animals made almost the same number of
both reference memory errors and working
memory errors so they were just as
likely to enter NARM that had never been
rewarded as they were to enter an arm
that they just visited maybe a minute
ago so this suggests that this is not so
much a mnemonic deficit per se it's not
that I can't remember but this reflects
more of a disorganized search strategy
and it also suggests that a noisy
prefrontal cortex one that has been
disinhibited that we've induced a bird
patterns of excitation may actually
interfere with certain aspects of
cognition that are not normally mediated
by the prefrontal cortex as I told you
this task doesn't that need any normal
prefrontal function if we shut it down
rats can perform this task just fine but
when we make it hyperactive aberrant
activity flowing out of the prefrontal
cortex may interfere with normal
patterns of neural activity in other
brain structures such as the hippocampus
that then lead to these impairments in
search behavior now another striking
aspect of these data they said this
qualitative nature of the impact the
increase in both working and reference
memory errors is exactly what you see in
patients with schizophrenia so this task
has been back translating for use with
human subjects where they have to
navigate through virtual space
using a similar type of environment
where we have a central platform and
eight arms radiating out in the center
the subjects have to search and go down
some arms to obtain money and other arms
contain nothing and when you take a look
at help schizophrenic patients perform
on this task you can see that they make
a compote of both working and reference
memory errors so again we see a
qualitatively similar type of deficits
one we just reduce inhibitory
transmission within the prefrontal lobes
to what we see in patients who have the
full-blown disorder so by not only I
hope to have convinced you one that
inhibitory GABA transmission in the
prefrontal cortex is crucial for
mediating certain aspects of cognition
and when we disrupt this transmission we
see impairments in cognition that in
many instances resemble what we see in
patients with schizophrenia what about
other symptoms what about these positive
symptoms we see these hallucinations
paranoia and the delusions could
dysfunction in inhibitory GABA
transmission relate to that as well well
we now know that these positive symptoms
are driven to a large part by increased
Dilton terrific activity as I mentioned
near the beginning of the talk this
likely is to be a major contributing
factor to the positive symptoms one
reason we say this is because if we take
patients with schizophrenia and give
them a pharmacological challenge you see
that patients tend to have much higher
levels of dopamine release compared to
healthy controls and the magnitude of
this increase in dopamine release is
positively correlated to the positive
psychotic symptoms they display so when
they see greater levels of dopamine
gliese they also tend to see greater
levels and intensity of these psychotic
symptoms now how might the frontal lobes
be regulating this well one thing we
know anatomically speaking is the
prefrontal cortex sends direct and
indirect projections
to the dopamine neurons in the midbrain
these projections are excitatory so we
could envision a situation where is that
if we were to cause hyperactivity within
the frontal lobes might this contribute
to hyperactivity within the dopamine
system as well so we address this issue
with both behavioral and
neurophysiological means in one
experiment we looked at how these
manipulations affected sensitivity to
the psychomotor effects of amphetamine
and feta mean increases dopamine
transmission caused an increase in
general locomotor activity and is a
standard assay that is used to validate
many different models of schizophrenia
in animals we know that patients with
schizophrenia that drugs like
amphetamine can exacerbate their
positive symptoms and they may show just
general sense increase sensitivity to
the second motor effects when we found
it when we dis inhibit the prefrontal
cortex find that animals were much more
sensitive to the locomotor effects of
amphetamine suggesting that we have
somehow turned on or amplified the
sensitivity of the dopamine system and
what's more when we recorded the
activity of dopamine neurons and how
often they fired in the pattern that
they fired we found that when we
disinhibited the prefrontal cortex we
saw an increase in the burst foreign and
the overall activity of these dopamine
neurons suggesting that in addition to
regulating these different aspects of
cognition if we reduce prefrontal gaba
functioning this may contribute to the
hyper dopaminergic functioning and
potentially some of the positive
symptoms that are associated with
schizophrenia now how do we measure
those positive symptoms in rats
how do we look with hallucinations we
can't really get to that and what does a
hallucinating rat hallucinate about well
cats meowing other rats squeaking Iggy
Azalea I don't know we may never know
but another component of schizophrenia
are these delusions and one component of
that seems to be that patients with
schizophrenia have problems in
discriminating between different stimuli
that may either be emotional emotionally
salient things that are important things
I should pay attention to and deal with
versus other stimuli that are otherwise
benign and neutral so the way I describe
this to my students is if I'm walking
across the street and someone looks at
me in a funny way I can probably
attribute that to a number of other
reasons and not pay too much attention
to that so why are they looking to me
well maybe they recognize me or maybe it
was just a random glance maybe I have
mustard on my face
maybe I'm just really good-looking today
I don't know but I can let that go but
the individual with schizophrenia will
see someone staring at them and will
averin tag that stinger saying oh this
is important why are they looking at me
and then they start to build a narrative
well they're looking at me because maybe
they're with the CIA maybe they're after
me maybe they can read my mind
and so this memory salience attribution
can contribute to the delusional states
associated with a disorder now that we
kinda can get to the studies with
laboratory rats well we can do that is
we can use what's called a
discriminative fear conditioning
procedure now fear conditioning tasks
are used very commonly to look at
emotional learning in animals where we
pair some stimulus a sound with his
shock and when you bear that shock when
you play that sound animals will show a
fear response
so in this essay what we can do is we
can teach the animal that if you hear
one sound that's associated with shock
and it learns that this particular sound
means something bad is going to happen
but we can also teach it when we play
another sound a completely different
sound nothing happens nothing good
nothing bad this is just a mess out and
I shouldn't worry about it
and then what we can do is take the
animal and put it in a situation where
it has to actively engage in behavior so
it might be pressing a lever for reward
and when we play that sound that was
never associated with shock it will keep
pressing that leaver it won't care it's
like this Charlotte this town Joan
doesn't mean anything to me but when we
press that tone that was associated with
the shock animals stopped pressing for
food they stopped reward see they
realized Oh something bad might happen
they go into behavioral arrest so it
evokes this particular fear response and
so animals can be pretty good at
learning when to show a fear response to
one stimulus and when not to care well
not to be show any emotional response to
another stimulus so using this procedure
what we found was a in control animals
animals that were just treated with an
infusion of saline we saw very good
discrimination what this graph is
showing you is how much they suppress
their ongoing reward seeking when we
play the two tones that were either
associated with shock or not and you can
see that when we play that shocked tone
the one that was associated with shock
and I'll show a lot of suppression of
their behavior and when we played the
tone the neutral tone that was not
associated with anything good or bad it
doesn't really affect their behavior
that much well what we saw was that when
we reduced prefrontal gamma transmission
we got a market deficit in this ability
to effectively to beat Saints here
animals showed less fear to the tone
they should be scared of the one that
they were field shocked and what's more
they showed greater fear to the tone
that was neutral to the tone that wasn't
associated with anything bad so they
showed a more generous stimulus
generalization whereas they couldn't
attribute which is the tone that is
important that is emotionally salient to
me versus which is the stimulus that I
shouldn't worry about and I shouldn't
pay any attention to so it suggests that
normal gaba transmission is involved in
discriminating between
emotionally salient and neutral events
but what was so striking about these
findings to us is that this pattern of
deficits we see when we reduce GABA
transfers is exactly what has been
observed in schizophrenic patients put
on the same type of tasks and what you
can see here is that control subjects
like we see neurons kill a greater fear
response to stimulus associate it with
shock
versus nothing or as patients with
schizophrenia show much poorer
discrimination so it suggests that
dysfunction and gaba transmission may
not just contribute to the impairments
in cognition but may also contribute to
some of the delusional aspects of the
disorder lastly I want to talk about the
negative symptoms a bit because this is
a domain of cognition that really has
not been studied as much in animals and
one of the key negative symptoms that is
associated with concern is a volition
this lack of drive to perform activities
or pursue meaningful goals and this a
volition may be mediated in part by
impairments in evaluating the relative
costs and benefits associated with
different behaviors or actions and we
can test this in both humans and animals
using certain types of effort related
decision-making tasks and so one way you
can test this in humans is you can give
them a choice between two options that
memmio yield them different magnitudes
of reward so if you you can give them
the choice where if you press one button
20 times with the index finger of your
dominant hand you might get one dollar
where is if you press another button
with the pinky finger of your
non-dominant hand now you might get a
larger reward anywhere from three to
seven dollars so if you work a little
harder you might get more reward and
these types of studies have been done in
patients with schizophrenia and relative
to healthy controls what they find is
those patients they choose the easier
option there
less likely to work harder to obtain a
larger reward compared to normal healthy
control subjects and what's more is he
found that these effects this reduced
motivation and impaired cost-benefit
evaluation who is greatest in patients
that showed the more elevated number of
negative symptoms so suggest that this a
volition and impairments and cost
benefit decision-making may relate to
this negative symptom ology well these
types of studies in humans were actually
translated from original studies that
were done in rats to measure these same
processes and so an asset we can use to
get to this aspect of decision-making is
shown here where here again we give the
animals be a choice between two options
if he chooses the high reward option it
has to press the laser anywhere from 2
or 20 times to get a larger for pendulum
or whereas if it chooses another option
the low reward option it only has to
press it once but here gets a smaller
reward so do you want to work a little
harder to get a bigger payout or do you
want to go lazy and just choose the
smaller reward what we found was that
when we disrupted prefrontal gaba
transmission like it's been observed in
schizophrenic patients these rats became
a little laser in terms of they did not
want to work as hard to get that large
reward but we saw these effects
primarily when they had a strong bias
for that large reward to begin with so
when the effort requirement was
relatively low when they only had to
press 2 or 5 times to get that large
reward when we made the cortex noisy it
dragged them down a little bit whereas
when they show the stronger preference
for the easy option we didn't see any
additional exacerbation in performance
so this was indication hey yeah when you
disrupt pre-fall Gaveston we may see
motivational deficits as well so
whenever we do these types of studies we
do some key control tasks to see
is this manipulation just impairing
their ability to discriminate between
larger and smaller rewards irrespective
of any cost may be associated with that
so we did a control experiment where we
had animals just now there's no effort
requirement just choose big reward
versus small reward all things being
equal and what we found here was this
annoying little effect where even under
these simple situations animals to show
to slight reduction in preference for
that bigger reward I mean they still
showed a strong preference they're still
accusing a big reward maybe eighty
percent of the time but it was just a
little bit smaller then what they did
under control conditions and then we did
a more formal array of studies well now
we varied the discrepancy between the
large and the small reward well now
they're accusing between six versus one
pellets four versus one pellets two
versus one pellets in every situation we
see that just making the cortex a little
noisy just impairs their reward
valuation process in just a bit so they
just like these small rewards a little
bit less or are less likely to maintain
focus on that larger reward more likely
to slip and just sample this smaller
reward and so okay well maybe they just
can't tell the difference between the
left and the right lever maybe we've got
some general impairment and
discrimination what that doesn't seem to
be the case because if we give them an
even simpler situation press one lever
to get two pellets versus another we
were to get the zero pellets here there
is no impairment in performance so what
this suggests is that disrupting gaba
transmission doesn't just affect
cost-benefit decision-making but main
deuce a subtle but more general
impairment in reward valuations so if
they have to choose between something
versus nothing there they can do that
just fine I would choose a lever
associated with reward versus nothing
but that one they have to choose between
something good versus something better
disrupting gaba transmission kind of
interferes with this math and this
valuation and there
just a little less likely to queues the
better option and this may also underlie
certain motivational deficits that we
see in schizophrenia and other
conditions that may be associated with
gaba transmission so just to summarize
what I've talked about today what I hope
to have convinced you is that reducing
prefrontal data transmission in animals
induces abnormalities cognitive function
dopamine transmission emotional
regulation and reward valuation and in
many instances the abnormalities that
we've seen animals are qualitatively
similar to what we see in schizophrenia
so we see impairments in attention
working memory spatial learning and
memory and cognitive flexibility we also
see increased dopaminergic activity and
aberrant salience attributions and also
certain negative symptoms related to
motivation and so these abnormalities
when we look at what we see in our
preclinical model ISM when we look at
the symptom clusters it suggests quite
strongly to us that these cognitive and
behavioral abnormalities associated with
schizophrenia may be driven in part by
alterations and perturbations in
inhibitory GABA transmission in the
frontal lobes and ultimately what I hope
to have shown you here is that the use
of pre clinical translational asses may
provide penetrating insight into the
mechanisms underlying abnormal behavior
and cognition associated with
psychiatric disorders now with that I
would just like to thank key members of
my research staff that were involved in
conducting these data including
Takeshima these studies I will be happy
to take any of your questions
[Music]
window doctor floresta will answer as
many questions as time permits so
without further ado let's hop into
questions with our first one dr. Flores
jo our first question of the day asks
are there any behaviors that do not
appear to be affected by reducing gaba
transmission the way they are I've been
emphasizing all the behaviors where we
do see some change that resembles
schizophrenia but it's not everything I
don't want to say that this is the only
thing that may be driving symptomology
and certainly other forms of cognitive
flexibility and discrimination learning
that I do discuss such as reversal
learning where animals now don't have to
change the strategy that they use but
they simply have to change a particular
stimulus they approach these types of
processes are suddenly impaired in
schizophrenia but when we disrupt
prefrontal gaba transmission we don't
see an impairment in this type of
executive functioning so if we teach
your rat just to always press the left
lever and then teach you to always press
the brightly for disrupting inhibitory
transmission within the prefrontal
cortex doesn't seem to be affecting that
behavior so there are certainly are
other aspects of behavior that may be
disrupted through other systems what
we're trying to say here is that this
function within this particular system
this preformed laboratory system may be
one of the drivers for many but not
necessarily all the symptoms
some promise but then upon further study
didn't now the idea of targeting the
gaba system directly is very tricky
because gaba is everywhere in the brain
We certainly have drugs that can enhance
gaba transmission like benzodiazepines
drugs like valium that are used to treat
anxiety and at higher doses can become
sedated these drugs by themselves are
not particularly effective at treating
the cognitive dysfunction but part of
this may be simply because they're
you're just causing a general reduction
activity so I think the trick is and
moving forward is finding a way to
normalize rather than just reduce or
enhance gaba transmission within these
particular synapses where we may be
having aberrant hyperactivity or reduce
gaba transmission now there may be other
ways of getting to that one thing we
know that dopamine transmission does
within the frontal lobes is that it can
enhance gaba activity and we actually
have some data to suggest that
impairments in working memory that we
see when we disrupt gaba transmission
can actually be ameliorated if we
enhance dopamine transmission within the
prefrontal cortex so I think moving
forward it's helping to identify which
synapses what and the types of receptors
in these synapses may have where gaba is
deficient and maybe rather than giving
drugs to just enhance gaba transmission
globally finding away nemours
preferentially target these receptors
perhaps using partial agonists or
stabilizers for these types of
transmission
thank you dr. fluoresce cow it appears
we only have time for one remaining
question today that question is what are
other disorders that may be the result
of faulty inhibitory transmission in the
frontal lobes as I told you at the
beginning our interest in this was
stemmed buyer interest in schizophrenia
but two other disorders where you can
see similar types of symptoms it's
certainly at least was some domains our
autism and certain aspects of depression
so certainly there's been an increased
focus on how deficient gaba transmission
may contribute some of the symptom ology
we see in in autism and certainly
certain parts of the frontal lobes and
depression seems to show this aberrant
hyperactivity which may also be meaning
to by dysfunctional gaba transmission
and so you can look at these three
diseases autism schizophrenia depression
they present quite differently but they
all may have some symptoms that are in
common and so I think as the field is
moving forward there is this whole
notion of this research domain criterion
where rather than identifying a disorder
by labeling it a certain named focus on
the symptoms of that disorders and try
to understand commonalities in the
neural dysfunction across those symptoms
and so across these different disorders
when we see these same symptoms may they
made me at least in some instances
driven by the same type of pathology in
this case deficient inhibitory
transmission
and for the opportunity I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and they clap roots for today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through June 2017 lab
routes will alert you via email when it
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event I'll
see you next time here at lab rates calm
goodbye